[російською] Одеса, мабуть,
єдине в України з великих міст,
[російською] де не було власного планетарію.
[російською] Це потрібно для освіти, для дітей.
[російською] Ми проводимо екскурсію,
у нас величезний потік
[російською] не лише одеситів, а і з усієї України,
[російською] та і не лише з України –
у нас бувають гості зі всього світу.
[російською] Оце от залишки.
[російською] Наша обсерваторія була
єдина в Радянському Союзі,
[російською] яка сама виробляла телескопи.
[російською] Ось тут механічні майстерні.
[російською] Електроніку я сам розробляв.
[російською] У нас в маяках оптичні майстерні,
[російською] вони виготовляли оптику.
[російською] І от все це збирали.
[російською] Ось залишок того,
що ми не встигли зробити.
[російською] Це ось задня частина телескопа.
[російською] Це основа дзеркала.
[російською] Сюди встановлюються механізми
розвантаження і дзеркала,
[російською] і потім встановлюється
[російською] на базі телескопу.
[російською] Ось вона, база.
[російською] Тобто, знизу, і всередину ставиться дзеркало,
[російською] ось сюди кріпляться вісі,
[російською] і ось він – телескоп метр тридцять.
[російською] Найбільший ми встигли
зробити метровий телескоп,
[російською] тобто діаметром в один метр.
[російською] Він зараз стоїть в Словакії,
[російською] тому що ми тоді самі не могли користуватися,
[російською] бо був розпад Союзу, і виникла проблема:
[російською] і ми його не могли довести.
[російською] Але мій друг, однокурсник —
[російською] він також астроном —
запропонував свою допомогу.
[російською] Він допоміг відновити його,
зараз телескоп працює.
[російською] Він стоїть у Словакії, тому що у степу
[російською] ставити великі телескопи
немає сенсу – потрібні гори.
[російською] У нас були станції на Кавказі,
в Середній Азії,
[російською] але знову ж ті самі фінансові проблеми,
телескопи стоять,
[російською] і ми навіть не знаємо, в якому вони стані.
[російською] Тут можна відчинити.
[російською] Це механізм ведення телескопу.
[російською] При великих збільшеннях,
скажемо, якщо поставити 240 крат,
[російською] то зірка вийде з поля зору
буквально за 20-30 секунд.
[російською] А ось цей механізм якраз веде телескоп,
компенсує обертання Землі.
[російською] Телескопу більше 130 років.
[російською] Його придбали в 1886 році.
[російською] Англійська фірма T. Cooke & Sons.
[російською] Ось тут табличка:
[російською] «Придбаний на кошти, пожертвувані
доктором Івановим в 1886 році».
[російською] Доктор Іванов був співробітником
медичного факультету,
[російською] і він залишив свій спадок
університету для наукових цілей.
[російською] Переважно на ці кошти і
був придбаний телескоп.
[російською] Практично з нього і починалась
астрономія в Одесі.
[російською] І це досі працюючий телескоп.
[російською] Річ в тому, що ми вже років 30
не дивимося на зірки –
[російською] в сучасних телескопах немає візуального каналу.
[російською] Це зараз єдиний телескоп,
в який можна спостерігати.
[російською] Він великої наукової цінності вже не має —
[російською] це вже, скоріше, як історія науки.
[російською] Тим не менш, для дітей,
для молоді, для студентів
[російською] він має велике значення:
[російською] вони можуть прийти подивитися
[російською] на зірки, на планети.
[російською] Як у нас в місті не стало планетарію,
[російською] я просто зробив ремонт,
[російською] тобто перебрав повністю телескоп,
відновив механіку,
[російською] особливих змін тут не проводилося.
[російською] Я потім знайшов окуляри,
[російською] які можна було змінити на більш
високої здатності, більш якісні.
[російською] Взагалі-то, і все.
[російською] По-різному виходило:
[російською] спостереження Марса, коли він з'явився;
[російською] цікаво, звичайно, подивитися на Місяць,
[російською] або Сатурн гарно побачити.
[російською] Ось тоді збиралися, дуже багато було людей.
[російською] Ми просто проводили спостереження.
[російською] Я вмикав телескоп, наводив, казав:
[російською] сьогодні буде видно таку от планету,
[російською] або такі от об'єкти, будь ласка,
приходьте, і люди приходили.
[російською] Ну, і зараз також у нас
[російською] постійно проходять якісь заходи, лекції, екскурсії.